[Music]
on this Wednesday night they dominated
the game but it wasn't enough
the goal to crush a 36-year drought at
the World Cup ends in defeat for
Canada's team demanding answers will
this government finally take
responsibility for the kids in their
care the search for accountability in
Ontario's child welfare system a terror
attack in Jerusalem
two explosions at bus stops and the
Canadian teenager killed
class avian flu fears has kind of come
back with a bit of a Vengeance right now
the unprecedented fight for poultry
farmers
International with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us the
Ontario government is in the midst of
overhauling its child welfare system and
accountability it says will be part of
its foundation yet the global news
investigative team found accountability
to be sorely lacking when we discovered
grave concerns about hats off a chain of
group homes in the province Global News
has obtained a secret draft report that
outlined issues at the company years ago
and uncovered the death of a 16 year old
which until now had not been made public
once again Carolyn Jarvis has our top
story tonight
Dwayne Ferguson was only six when
Hurricane Ivan hit Grenada and his
family sought refuge in Canada
in Ontario he was placed into the child
welfare system and bounced between 10
homes the last a group home in Hamilton
run by a for-profit company called hats
off
it was behind that house in 2014 he
would hang himself
he was 16 years old
if Ontario's Ministry of children didn't
know there were issues at hats off
before Dwayne's death it soon would in
2018 a report funded by the government
examined what happened to 12 kids who
died in care including Dwayne it found
it hats off a request to connect him
with community-based mental health
services did not occur
that same year the office of Ontario's
child advocate deemed hats off group
homes a hot spot of concern and launched
a review it would have ended up being a
contentious issue Global News obtained a
draft of that report including
interviews with kids who said there was
a high use of restraints and Punishment
we've concealed workers identities for
fear of reprisal boys would have nail
scratches from staff like hand print
marks around their wrists and stuff from
holding them behind their back all of
the boys were scared of us but the Ford
government shut down the child Advocates
office in 2019 and the draft report was
buried it was going to be in the media
for the minister and they would have had
to act to do something it didn't stop
the complaints from coming the ministry
acknowledged that they had received
numerous reports of concerns from hot
Soft Stuff workers say they also went to
supervisors police Children's Aid and
the Ombudsman who did anything no one
the end result see child welfare experts
is that there is no accountability there
isn't if we were talking about cats or
dogs in these homes and we were hearing
the stories as a society we'd be
outraged but somehow because their young
people were not outraged
so we went in search of answers
at hatsoff's head office
and at the stately home of its executive
director Gordon Naylor
but no one would come out to speak with
us instead they called the police he
just said that he didn't want you guys
on his property
in a written statement hatsoff said that
since the Advocates review it's created
a council of Youth appointed a team to
review serious occurrences and held
workshops for staff on enhancing
programming and understanding trauma it
says restraints are only used as a last
resort and there are mental health
professionals available for its youth
Minister Fullerton as for Ontario's
minister of children we were granted a
mere two-minute interview in which we
informed her of our findings well that's
horrific and that's exactly why we're
looking at redesigning this whole
program and while again there was talk
of accountability increasing the
oversight and accountability and
creating an environment in these
communities where children will be
supported when we asked about hats off
our time was up specific to the hats off
group home can I just can we ask you
what hats off group home your ministry
has known for years about serious issues
but I really appreciate your interest
and her handlers whisked her away
ultimately it's a system that's not
working nobody wants to to pull the the
lid off because then lots of people will
be held accountable and there are a lot
of people that are part of this being
complicit to it
despite heartbreak after heartbreak the
workers who knew Dwayne say he dreamed
of being reunited with his family
he was always full of hope they said
until it ran out
Carolyn Jarvis Global News
we have asked hatsoff to respond to our
reporting today the company emailed a
statement hatsoff says it refutes some
of the allegations but takes the issues
raised very seriously it says prior
incidents have been addressed and you
policies are in place to prevent them
from happening again it also says
Government funding is inadequate to
support the most vulnerable and complex
children global news reporting on this
story was at the center of a fiery
exchange today during question period at
the Ontario legislature
will this government finally take
responsibility for the kids in their
care investigate hats off and take
action so that no child spends another
day another minute in these horrific
conditions there is no room for in our
system for providers who refuse to
provide the quality care that's
necessary
you can find all of our reporting on
this story on our website globalnews.ca
global national well Canada waited 36
years for its World Cup opener today and
the historic match ended with a loss the
team was shut out by Belgium one nothing
there was a huge missed opportunity with
star player Alfonso Davies failing to
capitalize on a penalty kick Canada is
still waiting for its first ever goal at
the men's World Cup they have a lot of
support behind them though the team has
been a unifying force amongst Canadian
soccer fans as Eric Sorensen reports
many people hosted viewing parties and
pubs were bursting at the seams
what a moment Canada's men's soccer team
taking center stage in the world's most
popular sporting event the World Cup
[Music]
first time since in 36 years had to be
part of it in Qatar and across Canada a
brand new sports excitement uniting
every corner of the country like the
Olympics only more rare
fans in cities like Halifax all over the
country getting together to cheer them
on it's a pretty cool day I think to be
a Canadian soccer fan the match did not
disappoint the Canadians aggressive
carried the play to the heavily favored
belgians the second ranked team in the
world even earning a penalty kick a
chance for Alfonso Davies to score
Canada's first World Cup goal ever it
was not to be fans in Brampton watched
the moment
Canada's last and only World Cup in 1986
was unexceptional lost three matches and
never scored a goal
for decades World Cup excitement in this
country was found in Little Italy or in
German bars and English pubs where
Canadians cheered for their ancestral
home teams but fueled by a wave of
immigration the sport has exploded in
talent and popularity and Wednesday's
match showed that Canadian men's soccer
has earned its place among the world's
best a thrill for a new generation
watching at Alfonso Davy's childhood
home in Edmonton I never knew he was
from the Squanto like last year then one
Canada qualifa to World Cup I was super
excited in the end the Poise of the
European Club on one play was the
difference as Belgium scored the only
goal of the match
still for many Canadians it was a
revelation to see the Men's National
Team perform at this level athletic and
creative and gave Belgium all it could
handle can hardly wait for the next game
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
and a little later I'll talk to a
Canadian sports writer who was at the
game today about what it was like and
get his analysis of Canada's performance
there was some revealing evidence today
about how early Canada's Justice
Minister considered invoking sweeping
powers to end the so-called Freedom
Convoy protests in Ottawa last winter
texts between David lamatti and other
cabinet ministers were made public at
the inquiry into the use of the
emergencies act at one point he even
wonders about calling in the military
David Aiken explains
it would be days into the Ottawa protest
before Justin Trudeau's full cabinet
started thinking seriously about
invoking the emergencies act Trudeau's
Justice Minister started thinking about
it almost as soon as the trucks arrived
in Ottawa this text message was sent by
lametti to his chief of staff on Sunday
January the 30th that's the first
weekend the trucks were there asking
what authorities might be needed to
clear the protest the EA that's the
emergencies act lametti said he was just
being prudent I knew that that we had to
begin thinking about it whether or not
it was ever going to be an option as as
was the case with the pandemic but in
fact text messages from a Medi tabled as
evidence Wednesday seemed to show him as
a hawk relative to some other cabinet
colleagues to invoke the never before
used emergencies act in response to a
perceived inability of law enforcement
to deal with the protesters I was quite
frustrated I will admit in a text to his
friend friend and colleague Public
Safety Minister Margaret Mendicino
lametti presses him for police action
and even urges involvement by the
Canadian Armed Forces the CAF Mendocino
replies how many tanks are you asking
for I just want to ask Anita how many
we've got on hand lemetti did testify
later in the day he was never serious
about bringing in tanks this exchange is
meant to be a joke between two friends
Anita in that text was Anita Anand the
defense minister who testified Wednesday
using the Army against protesters was
the absolute Last Resort any minister of
National Defense
in a democracy
would be loathe
to deploy the Canadian Armed Forces
except in the most dire of circumstances
our country's soldiers are not police
officers on Thursday the commission will
hear from some of Trudeau's top advisors
Trudeau himself will testify Friday
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
two bomb attacks at bus stops in
Jerusalem have killed an
israeli-canadian teenager the explosion
is about 30 minutes apart went off at
the height of morning Rush Hour injuring
at least 18 people tensions between
Israel and Palestinians have been
building for months Israel has been
conducting night raids on the West Bank
but as our Europe bureau chief Crystal
gomancing Reports it's been years since
a bomb attack like this has happened in
Jerusalem
Arya shoe pack was killed in a roadside
bombing in Jerusalem Wednesday morning
the young Israeli Canadian was heading
to religious studies we condemned this
heinous act of Terror that claimed the
life of a young man injured too many
CCTV captured one of the explosions
Israeli police say they haven't seen
such coordinated attacks in the city in
years
explosive devices were left at two
different bus stops we found people with
blast injuries we found people with
injuries from shrapnel all of them
needed treatment at the scene as well as
people suffering from emotional shock
some of them were even taken away from
the scene and treated a little further
away far right politician itamar
bengaver visited one of the scenes using
it as a backdrop to demand Israel fight
Terror at all costs
even advocating for targeted
assassinations bengaver is angling to be
the public security minister with
sweeping powers in a coalition
government under Benjamin Netanyahu
thank you
Israelis however weren't the only ones
mourning the loss of a young life
Palestinians took to the streets to say
goodbye to a 16 year old killed Tuesday
night
his father says he got caught up in
clashes between militants and Israeli
forces during a raid in the West Bank
Hamas praised the bombings but did not
claim responsibility Israeli police have
vowed to find the perpetrators
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Crackdown at an iPhone Factory coming up
why workers held a protest and why
things turned violent in China
Russia pounded Ukraine with airstrikes
again today targeting several regions
including a suburb near the capitol
plumes of smoke Rose from an attack on a
building that killed five people dozens
of others were injured in key four
people died after missiles hit
residential buildings there Russia is
also stepping up its effort to cut off
power heat and water to ukrainians
airstrikes triggered a new round of
emergency blackouts and temporary
shutdown of three nuclear plants under
Ukraine's control today in a symbolic
vote the European Parliament designated
Russia as state sponsor of terrorism
citing its brutal and inhumane acts
against innocent civilians Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski says he's
grateful for the gesture and vows
Ukraine will rebuild
in China violence erupted at the world's
largest iPhone Factory as hundreds of
workers fought with authorities about
coveted quarantines and not getting paid
images are circulating on social media
showing some of the workers being beaten
and detained by people in white hazmat
suits using riot shields it's believed
they are police the rare scenes of open
descent in China mark an escalation of
unrest at the massive factory and reveal
deep frustration with the country's
severe zero covet policy Apple says it
expects lower shipments of its iPhone 14
models because of the disruption to
production at the plant
bird flu concerns ahead BC poultry
Farmers struggled to contain an Avian
Influenza outbreak
farmers in BC are under pressure because
of a nationwide outbreak of highly
contagious avian flu more than 275
thousand birds have already been called
in BC since the outbreak began in Spring
that's expected to rise nearly two dozen
commercial poultry operations are
dealing with cases of the virus right
now it rarely makes humans sick but as
nithu garcha reports it is taking a
heavy toll on poultry farm incomes
the ongoing outbreaks of Avian Influenza
are showing no signs of letting up the
stress is high watching barns be
depopulated that's there's a huge
financial impact BC poultry farmer
yushka Clark is within a 10 kilometer
radius of other operations where birds
have tested positive she's doing
everything she can to prevent it from
happening at hers we're definitely
changing our footwear and clothing and I
think limiting time spent going back and
forth to our farm into our barns for
sure there have been at least 10 new
cases confirmed in BC's Fraser Valley
region this week alone where those like
yoshka have been trying to get back on
their feet after heat domes and
disastrous floods over the last year
it's emotional we're getting a little
tired there's a lot of anxiety out there
Amanda pertain with BC egg and the BC
poultry Association says farmers are
facing unprecedented challenges VC has
had five outbreaks since 2004. this one
is quite different because the virus
seems to be a lot more virulent it's a
worldwide issue avian flu has spread
throughout Europe and into parts of
Africa first showing up in North America
in the fall of 2021. this causing
significant mortality
not only amongst domestic Birds but
we're also seen widespread die-offs
within Wildlife as well he says the
agency compensates infected Farms after
they're quarantined and all birds on the
premise are called BC's agriculture
Minister says there are also bans on
bird auctions and trading normal really
the pattern is it happens in the spring
and it happens in the fall and this year
we're just seeing it continue and so we
suspect that it's kind of entrenched now
though the virus is fatal to animals it
poses no risk to humans something yushka
is trying to remind consumers of keep
buying local products and that's
probably your best way to support our
farmers and there are ways to help those
who might be losing it all
Global News Abbotsford BC
what a moment for Canada next we go to
Doha for analysis of Canada's World Cup
debut
[Music]
well we knew going into its World Cup
game today that Canada had a fight on
its hands facing the number two ranked
soccer team in the world was never going
to be easy and in the end Canada did
lose to Belgium there were some missed
opportunities so what was it like to be
there well Joshua cloak can tell us he's
a staff writer for the athletic he's
author of a new book about the quest of
Canada's men's team to reach the World
Cup and he's in Doha Joshua hi there
Hi how are you I'm good look Canada went
into this game as the underdog everyone
knew that they knew that it didn't look
to me like they were outplayed though it
felt to me like a nail biter what's your
assessment
yeah I mean obviously outside of the
result I think this is about as good a
performance as Canada could have asked
for
um if you're a believer in kind of
advanced stats uh the advanced stats
tell you that Canada should have had you
know three goals tonight to Belgium's
one what was most impressive I think
throughout this game was just how Canada
didn't take their foot off the gas right
a lot of teams when they go to the World
Cup for the first time they cower they
get nervous Canada clearly didn't get
nervous at all they played with Pace
they played true to their kind of
authentic you know authentic style of
play which is one built on that pace and
so for them not to kind of cower to the
moment I think says a lot about the
maturity of this team especially given
how young some of their best players are
right absolutely the first half was
really dominated by Canada Canada
outshot Belgium do you think Canada had
Belgium rattled a bit
oh for sure after the game most Belgian
players gave full credit to Canada even
saying that you know this is a game that
that Canada probably should have won uh
Belgium's coach Roberto Martinez and
again this is a Belgian team that is the
number two ranked team in the world you
know is a World Cup favorite you know
Roberto Martinez the coach said for us
to keep a clean sheet against the team
like that is satisfactory that's not the
kind of compliment you usually give to a
team playing their first World Cup game
in 36 years so if you're Canada you have
every reason to be proud of the
performance I think the only thing you
have to work on moving forward is the
finishing considering Canada did have
all these chances some of them really
really quite great chances but you know
couldn't finish yeah well I wanted to
ask you about there's lots of talk about
whether Alfonso Davies should have taken
the penalty shot in the first half what
do you think
Alfonso Davies has scored both of the
penalties that he has ever taken for
Canada now again those penalties came
against the likes of the Cayman Islands
in Curacao and Jonathan David is you
know probably the more preferred penalty
taker considering he takes penalties for
Leo a very good team in France but when
it comes to the moment right who would
Canada want to possibly score their
first ever World Cup goal wouldn't you
want to give the keys to Canada's best
player ever
um I think he has the full support of
his team afterwards multiple of his
teammates said that so this is a
learning moment the World Cup is going
to be full of learning moments and you
have to give credit to Davies and
Augusto that he did show to step up in
the moment because it you know that's
the moment again a lot of players would
cower from hey Joshua really quickly 30
seconds ha so many of us would have
loved to have been there what was it
like inside the stadium today
it was special and I mean that because
you wouldn't know there were any Belgian
fans in attendance tonight you had Tom
Cochrane playing throughout the
loudspeakers you know an hour before the
game you had Canadian fans chanting this
is our house in Doha in their first
World Cup game in 36 years the
confidence in this team and its fans
were honestly quite overwhelming and I
think it bodes well for their next two
games fantastic Joshua cloak staff
writer for the athletic thanks so much
thank you
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Alouette Lake in Golden
Ears Park Maple Ridge British Columbia
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]